[Applaus]
[Musik]
fast 70 jahre lang bildet in deutschland
und frankreich traditionell jene achse
welche die europäische union ihre
vorgängerorganisation antrieb viele
jahrzehnte war es dabei innerhalb dieser
achse das ökonomisch stärkere
deutschland welches in fragen der
wirtschaftspolitik den ton angab und
genau dieses kräfteverhältnis hat sich
nun verschoben
angela merkel überlebte als kanzlerin
vier verschiedene französische
präsidenten durch die hinterließ ein
land welches in ideologischen
lagerdenken gefangen ist und in den
meisten bereichen immer mehr ins
hintertreffen gerät und so gewinnen die
französische position in brüssel immer
mehr an stärke der schärfere diskurs der
eu in der aussenpolitik führt ist ein
beispiel für dieses einfluss vor allem
aber steht die energiewende im
mittelpunkt dieses europäischen
showdowns die energiewende und eine
zentrale frage wie können wir die
wirtschaft dekarbonisierung das heißt
die co2 emissionen reduzieren ohne dass
wir gleichzeitig ihre
wettbewerbsfähigkeit ersticken
[Musik]
auf der suche nach einer antwort machte
frankreich sind in manueller corp eine
ankündigung die nichts weniger als ein
affront gegen die grundüberzeugung des
tektonischen nachbarn ist ihre
dependancen de france um die energie
unabhängigkeit frankreichs zu
gewährleisten die stromversorgung
unseres landes sicherzustellen und
unsere ziele insbesondere die kunststoff
neutralität im jahr 2050 zu erreichen
werden wir zum ersten mal seit
jahrzehnten den bau von kernreaktoren in
unserem land wieder aufnehmen
[Musik]
diese ankündigung kam zwar in einer zeit
explodierender energiepreise aber machen
wir uns nichts vor frankreichs
atomwirtschaft ist alles andere als ein
himmel auf erden gerade den neuesten
atomkraftwerke welche von der
electricité de france edf gebaut werden
verursachen nichts als probleme die
frage ist also warum setzt man grau als
eine skitour supply auf atomkraft
verspricht er hier wieder mal nur das
blaue vom himmel ohne einen konkreten
plan oder stellt eine neue generation
von atomkraftwerken lösung des
klimawandels und was für alle noch
wichtiger ist wird diese entscheidung
konsequenzen zu den rest der
europäischen union haben heute werden
wir hier auch visuell politik all diese
fragen beantworten zuerst werden wir
hierzu aber einen kurzen blick in die
geschichte
[Musik]
europas atommacht
frankreichs beziehung zur kernenergie
reicht lange zurück das französische
wissenschaftler um rebecca entdeckte die
radioaktivität und die wichtigsten
forschungsarbeiten an ihre
haupteigenschaft wurden von fähren marie
curie durchgeführt die menschheit musste
aber noch mehrere jahrzehnte warten um
die vorteile der kleinen kraft als
energiequelle zu nutzen erst 1954 begann
das erste kernkraftwerk der welt mit der
stromproduktion und dieses stand in der
sowjetunion zu dieser zeit schien die
atomkraft die zukunftstechnologie paar
extras zu sein schon bald gelangen ist
in anderen wirtschaftsmächten der udssr
gleichzutun im vereinigten königreich
den vereinigten staaten und natürlich
frankreich in den 1960 er jahren
verfügten die meisten industrieländer
über mindestens einen versuchsreaktor
und nach und nach wurden immer neuere
bessere und leistungsfähige reaktoren
entwickelt und dann kam das jahr
1973 zu diesem zeitpunkt war in
frankreich 8 kernreaktoren in fünf
verschiedenen anlagen in betrieb und
fünf weitere reaktoren im bau gut aber
was war das besondere am jahr 1973 nun
es war das jahr der ersten großen
ölpreiskrise
[Musik]
nachdem die arabischen länder aus
politischen gründen beschlossen hatten
ihre produktion zu drosseln das
vierfache sich der preis der erdöl
schlagartig damals wurde der meiste
strom in frankreich einem land ohne
eigene ölfelder in öl kraftwerken
erzeugt während nur etwa fünf prozent
aus der ersten generation von
atomreaktoren stammten
[Musik]
daher war die sogenannte ölkrise der
schlüsselmoment zur aktivierung des
sogenannten müssen plans im märz 1974
stellte frankreich der welt den plan vor
mit dem es ein völliger abhängigkeit von
ausländischem öl durchbrechen wollte das
ziel war es die größte atommacht in
europa zu werden
[Musik]
dieser plan sah vor innerhalb von zehn
jahren 80 atomreaktoren zu bauen und bis
zum jahr 2000 die zahlt 170 zu erreichen
dieses ambitionierte ziel wurde jedoch
nie erreicht letztlich wurden nur 58
reaktoren an 16 verschiedenen standorten
gebaut ein ziel wurde trotzdem erreicht
frankreich ist nach den vereinigten
staaten das land das weltweit die
meisten kernenergie produziert und
natürlich ist sie für frankreich die
größte quelle der stromerzeugung
[Musik]
was sich prozent des französischen
stroms sind nuklearen ursprungs der
höchste prozentsatz der welt angesichts
der stellung frankreichs in der
europäischen union tragen seine 56 in
betrieb befindlichen reaktoren außerdem
maßgeblich dazu bei dass ein drittel des
in der eu verbrauchten stroms aus
kernkraft stammt und da es sich um eine
energiequelle handelt die ohne den
ausstoß von co2 auskommt will frankreich
die quelle die im kampf gegen die
globale klimaerwärmung fördern
[Musik]
und ja ich weiß dass viele von euch
jetzt denken erneuerbare energien
produzieren doch auch strom ohne co2
auszustoßen aber das problem ist
natürlich dass wind und sollen die du
weißt vom wetter abhängig sind und was
passiert wenn der wind nicht weht oder
die sonne nicht scheint und
die antwort auf diese frage ist etwas
das der im jahr 2021 in ganz europa
gesehen haben als wegen der großen wind
laute plötzlich wieder sogar die aller
schmutzigsten energiequellen genutzt
werden musste deutschland kohle
übertrifft wind als primäre stromquelle
es war der offenbarungseid der
energiewende und die deutschen politiker
haben natürlich alles versucht um diese
tatsache noch dazu im jahr der
bundestagswahl so gut es ging vor ihren
wählern zu verschleiern oder
herunterzuspielen zu groß schienen die
gefahr dass viele deutsche wieder mit
der kernenergie liebäugeln könnten was
jedoch ideologisch einem enormen
gesichtsverlust der herstellung und
natura gleichkommen würde denn im
gegensatz zu dem von der deutschen
politik favorisierten und mit
milliardenaufwand gepushten formen der
erneuerbaren energiequellen bietet die
kernenergie eine stabile stromerzeugung
außerdem wird ihr preis kaum von den
schwankungen der uranpreise beeinflusst
natürlich hat sie wie ihr alle wisst
auch ihre nachteile die entsorgung von
atommüll ist einer davon und ich spreche
nicht nur von der sicherheit sondern
auch von den kosten in frankreich selbst
werden die kosten für das siegerprojekt
ein geologisches endlager für
radioaktive abfälle inzwischen auf rund
40 milliarden euro geschätzt weit
entfernt von den ursprünglich
prognostizierten 28 milliarden euro eine
riesige investition die aber nur die
spitze des eisbergs bildet
denn der muss mit lan führte dazu dass
zwischen den späten siebziger und
achtziger jahren etwa 80 prozent der
französischen atomreaktoren gebaut
wurden bei einer nutzungsdauer von 40
jahren bedeutet dies dass wir entweder
jetzt ihre renovierung investieren damit
ihr weiterer betrieb gewährleistet ist
oder wie ihr stilllegung in kauf nehmen
müssen
[Musik]
beide optionen würden frankreich
dutzende von milliarden euro kosten nach
schätzungen der edle würde die
stilllegung der reaktoren etwa 75
milliarden euro verschlingen während die
option die anlagen zu modernisieren und
zu überholen um sie noch ein paar
jahrzehnte weiter zu betreiben etwa 44
milliarden euro kosten würde die
französische regierung hat sich
schließlich für die letztere variante
entschieden aber achtung frankreich hat
gesetzlich festgelegt dass eine atom
kapazität 63 2 gigawatt nicht
überschreiten darf wenn es also zu
keiner gesetzesänderung kommt würde
jeder neue reaktor denen der
französische präsident angekündigt hat
die abschaltung eines alten reaktors
nach sich ziehen diese formale hürde ist
jedoch angesichts der massiven
technischen probleme mit denen die
französische atomindustrie in den
letzten jahren zu kämpfen hatte die
geringste sorge die griechen frage
lautet also ist sie wirklich bereit für
eine makro plan oder wird dieser auch
auf halbem wege stecken bleiben die
eines der müssen plan glaubt mir die
antwort auf diese frage ist für die
zukunft der energieversorgung und der
energiesicherheit ganz europas wichtiger
als alles andere
und von diesen beiden faktoren hängt
wieder direkt die wettbewerbsfähigkeit
der europäischen industrie die
geostrategisch abhängigkeit der eu von
russland und den usa und letztendlich
der lebensstandard aller bewohner des
kontinents ab also aufgepasst
harte zeiten
[Musik]
um beim thema kernenergie in frankreich
überhaupt mitreden zu können müssen wir
uns mit dem schlüssel unternehmen der
branche auseinandersetzen der edf der
electricité de france jedem gigantischen
staatskonzern den die französischen
atomkraftwerke gehören und der ganz
frankreich als quasi-monopolist mit
strom versorgt die edf übernahm 2018
75,5 prozent das kernreaktor geschäfts
von areva einem anderen staatlichen
unternehmen das angesichts der probleme
der französischen atomindustrie im
letzten jahrzehnt zur umstrukturierung
gezwungen war und diese nukleartechnik
sparte von ef heißt heute wieder frei
hat tom einnahme der die atomindustrie
frankreich seit 1950 er jahren trägt zu
vom atom gehört jedoch auch die
ehemalige nuclear abteilung von sales
welche heute als deutsche drama vom gmbh
firmiert
im jahr 2016 ordnete die französische
atomaufsichtsbehörde die abschaltung von
21 reaktoren an also von mehr als einem
drittel der edf reaktoren nach dem areva
mängel an 400 bauteilen eingeräumt hatte
die seit 01 65 jahre gestellt und in den
dampferzeugern verwendet wurden die
inspektoren waren besorgt über den hohen
kohlenstoffgehalt im stahl aus der
schmiede christo der bei einem
plötzlichen temperaturwechsel zu
steinbrüchen führen kann
was damals geschah ist ein gutes
beispiel dafür was passieren könnte wenn
es wird recht plötzlich seine atomkraft
bedeutet aufgibt die wärmekraftwerke
mussten infolge dieser entscheidung
plötzlich so viel kohle verbrennen die
seit den 80er jahren nicht mehr aber
warten denn bevor wir vom klima sprechen
machte sich die reduzierung der
atomstromerzeugung vor allem in den
geldbörsen der franzosen bemerkbar
der strompreis in frankreich schoss um
40 prozent in die höhe aber achtung er
stieg auch in vielen anderen
europäischen ländern in die frankreich
seinen strom exportiert 2017 haben sich
die dinge es war wieder beruhigt aber
der spaß war nicht billig das
französische staatsunternehmen schätze
die kosten der schließung und reparatur
der anlagen auf über eine milliarde euro
das allerschlimmste ist jedoch dass der
europäische druckwasserreaktor ebr ein
druckwasserreaktor der dritten
generation der so beginn des
jahrhunderts als das star projekt der
französischen atomindustrie vorgestellt
wurde der egf noch heute große
kopfschmerzen bereitet jahre sind
vergangen und derzeit nur zwei eps in
betrieb sie stehen in china und einer
musste bereits abgeschaltet werden
zwischen 2022 oder 2023 sollen weitere
apps in finnland und in frankreich in
betrieb gehen und zwar in kernkraftwerk
flamme wie ich könnte dir von all den
problemen erzählen die der e p1 harmonie
hatte aber es wäre besser wenn es direkt
französische wirtschaftsminister
brüderle marie lieber selber erzählen
würde
ich erinnere sie daran dass der reaktor
in flamanville etwas mehr als drei
milliarden euro kosten sollte unseren
bau 4,5 jahre dauern sollte er wird
viermal so teuer sein und seinen baugeld
15 jahre dauern das ist ein misserfolg
für die gesamte französische
atomindustrie
[Musik]
wie miss julie minister sagte haben alle
diese probleme und
kostenüberschreitungen den hof
frankreichs im bereich der kernenergie
einen schweren schlag versetzt noch vor
jahren war großbritannien der haupt
interessant für weitere investitionen in
die kernenergie und der installation der
eps des französischen stars unternehmens
heute sehen die dinge nicht mehr so
rosig aus das weist ein projekt bereits
gelegt worden aber ist überrascht
angesichts der ganzen der flops nicht
dass die briten die lust an weiteren
auftritten verloren haben
[Musik]
die beiden reaktoren die das kranke kind
erweitern sollen liegen mehrere jahre
hinter ihrem zeitplan zurück ihre
budgets wurden um millionen
überschritten ihre kosten sind auf 27
milliarden dollar gestiegen und sie
werden nicht vor 2026 in betrieb gehen
die genehmigung von zwei weiteren eps
der edf für das kraftwerk soll ist noch
in der schwebe es sieht so aus als ob
die briten am ende geneigt sein werden
den projekt nach zehn jahren debatte
doch noch bundes nicht zu geben zu groß
wäre wo der gesichtsverlust in der
zwischenzeit haben großbritannien und
rolls royce jedoch eine investition von
528 millionen dollar angekündigt um eine
neue generation kleinere atomreaktoren
zu entwickeln und aufzubauen die rede
ist vom snf dem small water reactor
einem kleinen modularen reaktortyp mit
einer leistung von nicht mehr als 300
megawatt zu vergleich herkömmliche
reaktoren leisten um die 1000 megawatt
das interessante daran ist jedoch dass
rolls royce versichert dass kleiner
bedeutet weniger probleme
[Musik]
es wird erwartet dass sma ist billiger
und schneller zu bauen sind als
herkömmliche reaktoren 2,5 milliarden
euro sollen sie im schnitt kosten wobei
man davon ausgeht dass dieser betrag in
zukunft auf 2,1 milliarden euro sinken
wird die snb soll in einer fabrik in
massenproduktion hergestellt und dann an
ihren endgültigen standort transportiert
werden ihr bau der drei bis vier jahre
dauern würde verspricht einfacher zu
sein als der von lpr reaktoren deren
fertigstellung mehr als zehn jahre
dauert mit sms ist aufgrund ihrer
geringeren leistung auch mit einfachen
mitteln ein viel höheres
sicherheitsniveau realisierbar sie
können zum beispiel passive
sicherheitssysteme verwenden die rein
auf physikalischen phänomenen beruhen
die von selbst funktionieren wie
konvektion schwerkraft oder widerstand
gegen hohe temperaturen und glaubte eine
drastische reduzierung der faktoren
menschliches und maschinelles versagen
stellen einen erheblichen meilenstein
[Musik]
ein beispiel groß reaktoren benötigen
punkten um im falle eines reaktor
störfalls die hitze schnell abzuleiten
so dass es zu keiner explosion kommt
doch diese pumpen müssen ihrerseits von
notstromaggregaten mit strom versorgt
werden da der reaktor abgeschaltet wird
dieser ganze mechanismus es bei sma ist
nun nicht mehr notwendig die
verschiedenen und vielfältigen facetten
von sms und auch von reaktoren der
vierten generation zu beleuchten würde
jedoch den ufern dieses videos eindeutig
sprengen heute wollen wir daher die
politischen aspekte klären und uns auf
die technischen lieber in einem anderen
video konzentrieren vergesst also bitte
nicht unseren kanal zu abonnieren und
auch das glöckchen zu aktivieren und
keines unserer zukünftigen videos zu
verpassen und in der beschreibung zu
diesem video findet ihr auch einen
paypal spenden link über den er unsere
arbeit unterstützen könnte damit wir
auch in zukunft mit interessanten videos
beglücken können an dieser stelle vielen
dank an all jene die die schon gemacht
haben ihr seid die besten
nun aber zurück nach frankreich
[Musik]
die eurozone will angesichts der
chancenreichen technik der sma es
nämlich nicht den anschluss verlieren
einen monat bevor er den bau neuer
reaktoren ankündigte sagte makro im
rahmen seiner ambitionierten agenda
front also frankreich 2030 eine
investition von über einer milliarde
euro für die entwicklung eigener kleiner
modularer reaktoren zu dabei kam es zu
einiger verwirrung weil medien die
beiden ankündigungen miteinander in
verbindung brachten es ist jedoch alles
andere als klar dass dies der fall ist
es ist sogar sehr wahrscheinlich dass
der plan von makro mehr dem entspricht
was in einem anderen in seiner eigenen
regierung in auftrag gegebene bericht
steht da 2018 durchgesickert ist
atomkraft ein bericht empfiehlt den bau
von sechs neuen eps diese sechs ets
sollen ein drittel weniger kosten als
der firma bp rund 50 milliarden euro
werden voraussichtlich ausreichen um sie
alle zu bauen das ziel wäre die vorteile
von skaleneffekte zu nutzen die edf
behauptet dass ihre nächsten eps von
kostensenkungen profitieren werden wenn
mehrere exemplare desselben dies einst
gebaut werden der vorteil den die
herkömmlichen projekte nicht nutzen
konnten soweit zumindest die theorie
damit die wirklichkeit wird hat
frankreich noch viel technologischer
entwicklungsarbeit vor sich ja vor allem
aber muss frankreich einen politischen
kampf gewinnen den es in brüssel führt
und erstaunlicherweise ist dieser viel
schwerer als alle technischen
herausforderungen denn der hauptgegner
der grow nation heißt in diesem fall
deutschland das sich in einer
ideologischen sackgasse festgefahren hat
und diese auch noch seinen nachbarn
aufzwingen möchte wenn es nach den
mächtigen und meinungsmacher in berlin
ginge sollte am deutschen wesen ganz
europa gewesen man träumt von der
energiepolitischen gleichschaltung des
containers der einstige langjährige
partner innerhalb der europäischen achse
ist also zum widerpart geworden ein
hochgradig ideologisiert es deutschland
in dem jede gesunde diskussion durch
toxisches lagerdenken erstickt wird und
das sich durch radikalen schwenks wieder
in rivalität frankreich in stellung
gebracht hat weckt jedoch erinnerungen
und alte grausame längst überwunden
geglaubte zeiten die deutschen täten
sehr gute an die kritik und die
befürchtungen ihrer nachbarn nicht zu
delegitimieren indem sie sie
unberechtigterweise in die radikalinskis
ecke schieben so wie zb jüngst wieder
beim polnischen vize ministerpräsidentin
kaczynski welcher der neuen shows
regierung den vorwurf machte sie wolle
aus der eu ein viertes reich der gleich
gleichmacherei machen deutschland sollte
dringend wieder zu einer kultur der
dialogbereitschaft statt der ausgrenzung
andersdenkender zurück wenn sonst wächst
ist wieder so eine gefahr für sich
selbst und andere heran um es ganz klar
zu sagen wir stehen hier vor einer
schicksalsfrage ob ein in vielfalt
geeint ist friedliches und
prosperierendes europa möglich ist die
achse paris berlin eier zu gewaltig wie
noch nie und der ausgang dieses kampfes
wird dem kontinent auf viele jahre
treten nicht nur was die energie
versorgung angeht sondern auch im
hinblick auf die langfristige macht
balance innerhalb der eu und ihre
weitere ausrichtung wir sollten uns
tatsächlich anschnallen denn der
showdown steht kurz bevor
quid pro quo
die europäische union steht kurz davor
eine wichtige entscheidung im kampf
gegen den klimawandel zu treffen zur
debatte steht die sogenannte taxonomie
ich bin sicher dass viele von euch
wissen dass die taxonomie in der
biologie dafür zuständig ist tiere und
pflanzen nach ihren merkmalen zu
klassifizieren nun die europäische
kommission versucht hier analog
festzulegen welche energiequellen als
ökologisch nachhaltig eingestuft werden
[Musik]
die idee dahinter ist dass die taxonomie
der energiequellen zu einem leitprinzip
für die europäische union wird wenn es
darum geht zu entscheiden welche
industrien subventioniert werden können
die taxonomie soll auch den
finanzmärkten bei der beurteilung helfen
in welcher energieträger es sich lohnt
zu investieren
es geht also um die zukunft jeder 10 die
quelle ob die zugangs zu subventionen
und billige kapital erhält oder falls
sie ausgeschlossen wird viel
komplizierter finanziert werden muss bis
hin zu jenem punkt dass sie völlig
unrentabel wird kurz gesagt alles was in
die eu taxonomie für nachhaltige
aktivitäten aufgenommen wird wird mit
geld zugeschüttet vom staat und von
investoren alles was nicht reinkommt
wird im grunde erstickt und in der
bedeutungslosigkeit verschwinden
unabhängig davon ob auf dem markt eine
nachfrage besteht oder nicht du dir
vorstellen kannst kämpft frankreich mit
aller macht dafür dass die kernenergie
in die brüsseler pläne aufgenommen wird
und das wichtigste ist dass sie nicht
allein sind neben frankreich haben auch
tschechien bulgarien kroatien slowakei
slowenien finnland ungarn polen und
rumänien stellung bezogen außerdem
werden diese länder auf dem letzten
energieministerrat auch von den
niederlanden und schweden unterstützt
wir sprechen hier von zwölf der 27
mitglieder der europäischen union
betroffen wären jedoch nicht nur
eu-staaten lass mich dies mit einem
kleinen aber sehr aktuellen beispiel
verdeutlichen in den vergangenen tagen
mussten 15 der insgesamt 56
französischen atom reaktoren wegen
wartungsarbeiten oder pannen vom netz
genommen werden allein diese kleine
temporäre abschaltung dazu geführt dass
massiv kohle und sogar alte ölkraftwerke
wieder hochgefahren werden mussten um
einen blick auf zu verhindern und in der
schweiz sind die strompreise daraufhin
auf das sechsfache explodiert der grund
nun das kleine alpen dann ist auf
stromimporte aus frankreich angewiesen
weil es von wasserkraft abhängig ist die
wasserkraftwerke im winter jedoch nicht
genügend strom zur selbstversorgung der
schweiz liefern ihr seht also wenn es um
energie geht ist redundanz vielfalt und
ein gesunder energiemix das alpha und
omega aber wartet einen moment denn
trotz all dieser argumente ist eine
bestimmte gruppe von ländern alles
andere als bereits diese tatsache
anzuerkennen
diese oppositionsgruppe wird von
deutschland angeführt dass im jahr 2022
denen nach dem reaktorunglück in
fukushima angekündigt die atomausstieg
vollziehen wird weitere länder sind
österreich luxemburg dänemark portugal
und spanien berlin kämpft dabei allen
ernstes gegen die anerkennung von
kernenergie jedoch dafür dass erdgas als
umweltverträglich eingestuft wird nur
weil bei seiner verbrennung etwas
weniger co2 ausgestoßen wird als bei
kohle die derzeit eine der
hauptenergieträger ist er in diesem
punkt haben jedoch kreta thonberg und
andere klimaaktivisten eindeutig recht
wenn sie diese angeblichen
klimaschutzmaßnahmen als absoluten fag
entlarven und auf die unterwanderung der
eu energiepolitik durch die lobby
verbände der gasindustrie hinweisen der
verdacht dass gerade in deutschland
nicht nur ex kanzler schröder seit
vielen jahren auf der gehaltsliste von
gas draufsteht ist gigantisch ist aber
ist die europäische kommission am zug
welche den konflikt lösen soll sie hat
von den europäischen institutionen einen
delegierten rechtsakt zur festlegung des
rahmens für die taxonomie erhalten und
was sagen sie dazu nun würden wir uns
doch mal an was kommissionspräsidenten
ursula von der leyen ende oktober gesagt
hat
es ist offensichtlich dass wir mehr
erneuerbare und saubere energie brauchen
daneben brauchen wir eine stabile
energiequelle die kernenergie und in der
übergangsphase natürlich auch erdgas
deshalb haben wir diesen april eis
kommission erklärt haben unseren
vorschlag für eine taxonomie vorlegen
kann verrät usa taxonomie pause dieser
vorschlag für die taxonomie wird als
delegierter rechts bugs vorgelegt das
heißt es gibt nur zwei möglichkeiten ihn
abzulehnen entweder durch eine mehrheit
des europäischen parlaments oder durch
eine qualifizierte mehrheit des
europäischen rates das ist keine leichte
aufgabe zu sein die frage ist wird
brüssel den mumm haben berlin die stirn
zu bieten
nun alles deute darauf hin dass ist
diese häufig in der eu auf eine quid pro
quo vereinbarung hinauslaufen wird mit
anderen worten etwas im austausch für
etwas anderes du weißt schon deutschland
gibt auf der einen seite nach frankreich
auf der anderen die europäische
kommission würde damit sowohl das
zumindest dass man jetzt sehr lange
übergangszeit als auch atomkraft als
ökologisch nachhaltig einstufen und alle
waren zufrieden sein alles andere wäre
wohl zu riskant und würde die fronten
innerhalb der eu nur weiter verhärten
diplomatie made and brothers in ihrer
reinsten form eben der
kommissionsvorschlag soll dann
frühestens im januar 2022 veröffentlicht
werden der deutsche bundeskanzler scholz
hatte jüngst eingeräumt dass es weiter
keine einigung zu dem thema gibt seine
österreichische kollegin hammer
berichtete nach dem eu gipfel in brüssel
von einem intensiven regen der staats
und regierungschefs über dieses thema
wahrscheinlich verlieren wir den krieg
gegen die hammer von einer aufnahme der
atomenergie in den katalog der
nachhaltigen energieformen aus aber
jetzt ist die frage an dich gerichtet
glaubst du das ist frankreich endlich
den segen größten ist für die
kernenergie bekommt und würdest du dir
wünschen dass dein land auch einen plan
zum bau neuer atomreaktoren umsetzt der
immer sind auf eure meinung zu diesem
thema schon gespannt ich hoffe also dass
auch dieses video gefallen hat was ja
gibt es gibt ein leichtes mit euren
freunden vergesst nicht das abo mit
glöckchen um keines unserer videos mehr
zu verpassen und unterstützt unser
arbeitet auch mit einer kleinen spende
über den link in der beschreibung unter
diesem video olivo arabien
[Musik]